네 여러분 오늘은 대한민국에서 가장
비싼 명동에 와 있습니다 명동 역사를
좀 설명드리자면 일제 강정기 때 일본
상인들과 기업들이 이쪽으로 이전하면서
여기 주변에 상권들이 좀 발달되기
시작했는데 60년도 70년도에 패션
사업이 엄청
발달됐다 그이면 여기에 유명한 패션
업체들이 좀 많이 들어왔거든요 진짜
뭐 정장 가게라 이런 패션들이 좀
많이 들어오면서 이런 친구들이 새로운
트렌드를 알기 위해서 이쪽으로 좀
많이 명동 상권을 이용했다고 합니다
그리고 여기 인근에 명동 극장이
있는데 명동 극장을 중심으로 이런
예수가 좀 많이 몰려오면서 이쪽으로
좀 상권이 발달되기 시작됐고 그리고
무엇보다 여기가 금융 사업이 되게
발달됐다 많잖아요 그래서 여기 뭐
우리 은행이라는 하나 은행이라는
본사가 있을 정도로 여기에 금융
산업이 매우
에 이런 사채업이 되게 많이
발달됐다 돈 빌리러 간다 뭐 이런
이야기가 있을 정도로 여기에 현금
부자들이 좀 많았습니다 한 7
80년도에 진짜 전화 한통으로 제
몇십억 몇백억 몇 천억을 빌릴 정도로
이런 대기업 총수들도 여기에 돈을
빌리러 왔다라고 합니다 그리고 또
유명한 일화 중에 진짜 우리나라 주식
고수 중에 한 분인 명동 백할머니
아마 아실 것 같은데 미래셋 지금
박현주 회장님의 어떻게 보면
스승입니다 박현주 회장님이이 백
할머니를 만나기 위해서 진짜 매일같이
찾아와서 제발 제자로 해 달라고 진짜
허드레 리까지 했다라고 하는데 백
할머니가 그렇게 좀 돈을 모아서
국채를 투자하고 그리고 한
60년대부터 이제 주식을 본격적으로
투자했다고 합니다 근데 그때 당시에
그 중동 붐이 불면서 건설 기업들의
주가가 엄청 올라갔어요 정말
대한민국의 최고 부자가 될 정도로
그런 주식 투자로 돈을 벌었다고
합니다 명동이 금융 예술 뭐 이렇게
패션 그리고 이제 이런 외국 문화를
빨리 받아들이면서 이런 외국인들의
관광 명소로 좀 떠오른 거 같아요
지금 보시면 알겠지만 여기 걸어다니는
사람 명 중에 한 여덟명 아홉 명이
다 외국인일 정도로 진짜 한국 오면
꼭 와야 되는 그런 관광 명소 중에
하나가 됐습니다 그래서 제가 지금
밀리오래 앞에 있는데요 앞에 건물이
우리나라에서 가장 비싼 건물입니다
그래서 제가 직접 가가지 한번
보여드리도록 하겠습니다
가시죠네 지금 뒤에 보이는이 네이처
퍼블릭이 들어간 건물이 우리나라에서
가장 비싼 건물입니다 그래서 공시지가
20년 동안 1위를 기록할 정도로
되게 비싼 건물인데 공시 지가가 무려
평당 5억 7천만 원이 넘습니다
대지가 51평 정도 되는데 공시지가만
봤을 때도 290억 거의 300억에
달할 정도로 매 비싼 그런 건물이라고
보시면 될 거 같아요 그리고 네이처
퍼블릭이 2010년도부터 들어와서
거의 한 14년 넘게 들어와 있는데
정말 위치가 너무 좋고 그때 당시에
미리 선점해서 되게 장기간 어떻게
보면 안테나 매장으로이 네이처
퍼블릭을 홍보하기 위해서는 정말 너무
잘한 선택이라고 보면 될 거 같습니다
그래서 명동역 나오자마자 있어 가지고
위치가 좀 제일 좋은 곳이라고 보시면
될 거 같습니다 그래서 우리나라에서
제일 비싸지 않나 그렇게 생각을
합니다
[음악]
최근 매각 사례를 말씀드릴 건데 저
뒤에 보이는 저 성형외과 건물인데
돼지가 한 32평에 연면적이 한
87평 정도 돼요 그래서 한 4층
정도 규모의 빌딩입니다이 건물이 올해
무려
235억 원에 매각이 됐어요 대지
평당가로 7억 4천만 원 정도의
매각이 됐습니다 정말 어마어마한 그런
땅인데 그 정도로 명동 땅값이 굉
굉장히 비싸다고 보시면 될 거 같아요
근데 위치가 네이처 퍼블릭 바로 앞에
있는 건물로이 정도 건물이 과연
235억이야 할 정도로 우리나라에서
가장 비싼 곳이라고 보시면 될 거
[음악]
같습니다네 그래서 바로 저기 뒤에
보이는 저 금강제약 건물이
우리나라에서 가장 비싸게 매각된
사례입니다 저 건물이 다가 아니라 저
건물에 한 1분 정도 면적이라는 될
거 같아요 그래서 대지가 한 19평
정도 되고 연면적이 한 100평 정도
됩니다 그리고
1971년도에 준공된 되게 낡은
건물을 리모델링해서 사용 중이고요
그리고 그때 당시에는 건폐율이 한
100% 정도 되는 건물들이 워낙
많았어요 지금 건폐율은 거의 100%
정도 되는 거라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다 우리나라에 유일하게 대지
평당 10억이 넘는 그런 매각
사례라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다
유일하게 아까 아까 보셨겠지만 7억
4천에 매각된 사례도 있고 어
유일하게 10억이 넘은 건물이니 어
여러분들 기억하 으면
좋겠습니다 그래서 지금 밀리오래
쪽에서 나와가지고 이렇게 쭉 걷고
있는데 어 저는 그 밀리 오래가 정말
좋은 사례라고 생각하는게 저렇게
만들어 가지고 망했던 건물들이 되게
많습니다 그래서 뭐 예를 들면 저희가
막 동대문 그런 APM 건물이라는
저렇게 소유권을 잘게 쪼개서 판 그런
건물들이 되게 많거든요 지금 저
밀리오래 건물도 원래 그 그랬어요
다망 있 건물이었고 다 비어 있던
그런 건물이었는데 최근에 바꿨습니다
소유자가 한 200명이 넘었는데 한
어떤 기업에서 200명을 일일이
찾아가 가지고 다 동의를 받았어요 그
기업에서 마스터 리스로 들어왔습니다
마스터 리스가 뭐냐면 소유주 임대를
하는 거예 임대를 하고 다른 사람한테
재임대하는 방식으로 이제 임대를
진행하는 겁니다 소유자 입장에서는
어찌됐든 최소한의 임대료를 계속
봤거든요 마스터리로 살아난 그런
대표적인 건물이라고 보시면 될 거
같아요 사실 위치가 굉장히 좋았는데
계속 좀 비어져 있어 가지고 좀 되게
좀 안타깝긴 했었거든요 정말 쉽지
않은 일이지만 그 200명이 넘는
그런 소유자를 직접 찾아가서 그렇게
동의를 받았다는 거에 저는 되게
놀랬고 면적도 막 한
10m 정도 될 정도로 되게 잘개
자하게 쪼개 놔 가지고 임대하기 쉽지
않았지만 저 기업이 전체를 다
마스터리스 하면서 기업이 한 아홉 개
정도로 되게 줄어들었습니다 그래서
지금 저게 올리브영 매장 같은
경우에는 바로 이제 명동역 나와서
있는데 장사가 너무 잘 돼요 하루
매출이 1억이 넘는다고 합니다 그러면
한 달에 거의 한 40억 원대 정도
매출이 발생되고 1년으로 치면은 거의
한 500억 정도 저 한 매장에서만
어 그 정도로 나올 정도로 장사가
굉장히 잘되는 어 그런 자리라고
보시면 될 거
[음악]
같아요 저는 명동의 대표적인 맛집인
명동 교자 앞에 와 있습니다 뒤에
보이는 거 같이 사람들이 지금 굉장히
좀 많이 어 왔다 갔다 합니다 그래서
그 정도로 장사가 되게 잘되고 명동
내에서 아마 되게 오랫동안 유지된
그런 식당이라고 보시면 될 거 같아요
그래서 96년도에 창업해 가지고
지금까지 이어온 그런 식당이라고
보시면 될 거 같고 그리고 사장님이
되게 잘하신게 건물을 직접
매입하셨으면 의 진심이신 거 같아요
그래서 직접 매입해서 운영하는
방식으로 운영되고 있고 그리고 제게
되게 놀라운게 작년에 매출을 좀
보니까 작년 매출이 무려 한 290억
정도 되더라고요 근데 거기서 더
놀라운 거는 순 수익률이 무려 40%
됩니다 남는게 너무 많은 회사예요
그러니까 어떻게 보면 되게 알짜
기업입니다 그래서 영업 이익만 봤을
때 거의 한 90억 원대 거의
100억 원대 남는데 원래 일반
제조업이 그 정도 영업 이익을 내려면
진짜 매출이 한 천억 돼야 되거든요
무엇보다 영업 이익을 많이 낸 이유
중에 하나가 직접 매입한 부분도 있을
거예요 그래서 보통 여기가 임대료가
워낙 높기 때문에 사실 그냥
일반적으로 장사하면 임대료 내고
나면은 남는게 별로 없거든요 이분
같은 경우에는 직접 건물을 매입해서
물론 대출 이자가 나갈 수가 있지만
그게 임대료보다 저렴하기 때문에 그런
부분에 있어서 이익률이 좀 많이 나지
않았나 그렇게 생각을 합니다
[음악]
네 저는 명동 성당에 와 있습니다 어
명동 성당은 우리나라 최초의 가톨릭
성당이라고 보시면 될 거 같은데 정말
오래된 건축물이 1898년에 지어져서
되게 오랜 역사와 그런 상징적인 그런
건물이라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다 어
제가 일단 오늘 명동을 돌면서 느낀
점이 외국인들이 정말 많아졌구나 좀
많이 체감을 했는데 제가 코로나
한창일 때도 명동을 좀 와봤어요
그래서 반 이 다 비어 있을 정도로
매우 공실률이 높았는데 지금 오늘
가서 또 느낀 점이 진짜 공실이 없을
정도로 꽉 차 있습니다 그래서
공실률이 50% 6%지 내려왔어요
그래서 6% men 거의 자연 공실률
수준이거든요 그래서 진짜 명동에 있는
건물들이 다 차 있다라고 보시면
됩니다 조금 달라진게 뭐냐면 예전에는
이런 버스 빌려 가지고 관광 패키지
여행을 참 많이 왔거든요 요즘의
트렌드는 패키지 여행보다는 그냥 각자
개별 여행을 많이 와요 개별 여행이
좀 인기가 많아지면서 좀 이렇게
전체적으로 어 활기를 띄는 거
같습니다 그니까 외국인 관광객들도
되게 많고 임대료도 되게 높다 보니까
빌딩 가격이 굉장히 좀 높은데 근데
그거와 반해서 명동의 최대 큰 단점은
너무 외국인들의 의존도가 되게 높은
거 같아요 그니까 국내 사람들이 많이
안 옵니다 저도 명동을 사실 잘 안
와요 그리고 요즘 젊은 사람들은 특히
더 명동을 안 옵니다 차라리 뭐
성수나 한남을 이쪽으로 좀 많이가
지금은 외국인들 때문에 뭐 이렇게
임대료라도 뭐 장사도 너무 잘되고
빌딩 가격도 계속 좀 오르는 지역이긴
하지만 국내 사람이 없는게 가장 큰
단점인 거 같습니다 명동의 건물을
투자하신다기에
대체적으로 다 보면은 오래된 건물들이
되게 많아요 그래서 대부분 다 한
60년도 70년도 된 건물들이 워낙
많기 때문에 땅 면적도 중요하긴
하지만 공간 활용도를 보실 필요가
있습니다 활용도 에 따라서 임대료
수준도 되게 달라지고 빌딩 가격도
달라집니다 도로마다 임대료 수준
차이가 너무 많이나요 임대 시세
조사도 되게 체계적으로 하실 필요가
있습니다 명동 상권을 좀
전망하면서 제가 봤을 때 좀 더 많이
올 것으로 예상이 됩니다 그러면 명동
상권은 더 좋아지고 빌딩 가격은 더
오를 것이라고 예상이 돼요 명동
상권의 가장 큰 문제점인 어떻게 하면
국내 사람들을 오게 할지 어떻게하면
이런 젊은 사람들이 명동 상권을
이용하게 될지를 좀 생각해보고 그리고
임대료 수준이 워낙 높기 때문에
어떻게 하면 임차인들이 이렇게
상생하며 오랫동안 상권을 유지할 수
있을지 한번 좀 고민해 보면 좋을 것
같습니다 오늘 영상은 여기까지 빌딩은
[음악]
사람 h